the indicted and since pardoned
trump associate roger stone is
predicting that donald trump is going to
be indicted that an indictment of donald
trump is coming and this story didn't
get
much attention over the memorial day
weekend but roger stone
appeared with conspiracy theorist alex
jones
and uh of course he says it's a witch
hunt of course he says it's nonsense of
course he says
these are going to be trumped up
political charges and it's trash but
roger stone
says an indictment of donald trump is
coming take a look at this video
the globalists love symbolism don't they
well i would be shocked if they
did not come forward with a fabricated
indictment
for bank fraud or tax fraud against the
former president
by manhattan district attorney cyrus
vance
of an elected democrat the son of cyrus
van senior
the worst secretary of state in american
history the man who botched
the iranian hostage crisis under jimmy
carter by the way uh cy vance is not
exactly a non-corrupt politician himself
okay so roger stone starts carrying on
there but the big point is
stone's saying he'd be shocked if there
isn't
some indictment of donald trump we
previously reported
that the grand jury is being convened
they are looking at evidence
they will decide on charges so this is
real in that sense
but trump is lawyered up presumably has
top lawyers
already or almost ready to represent him
if indeed this were to happen and i
continue to believe
that donald trump's real level of
risk is quite low of ending up in prison
tiny tiny tiny as i've said before but
what about the trump children not barron
and tiffany
but the ones involved in trump's
businesses donald trump jr eric trump
ivanka trump
they are now being advised to lawyer up
personally
because even though any charges if they
ever come will likely be related to
trump organization activity
the trump organization legal team really
represents the interests of the
organization so here is
frank figluzzi former assistant director
for counterintelligence at the fbi
explaining this to msnbc
but nicole as we're talking about
witnesses we might as well go ahead
and talk about kind of those big big
witnesses which is
are we going to see this grand jury um
a subpoena or or are we going to see
subpoenas to testify before this grand
jury for people like
eric don jr and ivanka
and if so are they going to plead the
fifth amendment
against self-incrimination
well you mean you raised that i mean i
remember when the new york times
big investigation into the trump taxes
came out
and all that liability that he had and
you were part of our coverage um
about the national security implications
of that right that he was in so much
debt
if the new york times learned that
certainly foreign government could have
but one of the one of the line items
were big
transfers to ivanka trump would you
guess
that they all have lawyered up in terms
of criminal defense attorneys
i wrote a column about that and so
they better have to individually layered
up
yeah they they have had to have lawyered
up because they may have already made
the mistake
of casually speaking to the
organization's
attorneys and the organization's
auditors about you know what they knew
and what their role was
big mistake if they'd done that because
the organization doesn't represent them
the organization's lawyer's mission is
to preserve the organization
not the individual executives and
officers it becomes
every man or woman for themselves and in
this case the men and the women
happen to be family so this has every
possibility of escalating dramatically
and one more thing from roger stone here
to get back to him roger stone predicts
that the timing of these indictments uh
will be around when the so-called audit
in arizona wraps up
this was mixed between ranting about
other things of course
the damn loan well let's be let's be
very clear in other words as you said it
earlier you show the man i'll show you
the crime
they're allowed to root through this
man's business record of 40 years in
which he built a real estate
empire second to none combing for a
crime they have no evidence of a crime
they have no probable cause
it is disgraceful but i do think it is
going to happen
and don't be surprised if the
announcement comes at the exact time
that we learn the truth about maricopa
county arizona
don't be surprised because i see that
coming so that ominous timing predicted
by roger stone
is this just nonsense or does roger
stone actually know something or is he
just guessing
after all roger stone told me during our
interview that he would never be
indicted by the fbi
and he was indicted by the fbi so maybe
roger stone just isn't the guy to listen
to about this stuff
or maybe roger stone does know something
but it's going to be a very interesting
upcoming six months
and um probably the right advice for the
adult
trump kids to lawyer up my guess is they
probably have already
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service
at privacy.com pacman i've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches
and identity theft and it's free and
like i said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman